and welcome to you from myself Steve
Falconbridge joined by Fergus on camera
we are out in Toomer in sabi sands with
the degrees of 33 degrees Celsius and 89
degrees Fahrenheit it is a nice warm day
the Sun is beating down we have
developed a bit of a sweat getting the
vehicles ready but we are excited and we
were out on a mission I am joined out
there by Scott Dyson he's on vehicle as
well as Taylor and we're going to try
and show you one of the best game brave
safaris that we can please feel free to
send through your questions - at Safari
love or hashtag Safari Live and follow
us on that the YouTube stream sent to
your comments or questions see how we
can accommodate you this afternoon I am
going to go and try with Fergus and find
that beautiful Tandy and her cub it's
been a while I was watching the videos
from this morning and she has grown so
much so that is my mission this
afternoon to go and have a look and
obviously whatever we find along the way
Scott has given me some rough directions
so we're gonna see if we can manage to
relocate on that beautiful animal so
please jump on the board in the front
row seat with us come and have a look
and while we go we're gonna jump over to
Taylor who's already found herself a big
five animal I know can you believe it
starting off the sunset safari with my
favorite animal but there's one to the
right that I want to show you that's
even more exciting because it is having
a little bit of a mud wallow how cool is
this
of course this elephant is way more
important than me introducing ourselves
so we shall watch it for a little bit
and then I will say hello at some point
although you're really good a glimpse of
my blond ponytail
for those of you that are just joining
us for the first time on server re-live
it's great to have you on board remember
you can chat to us all you would do is
hashtag sorry live and then talk to us
via the YouTube chat but I'm Taylor
that's my name and behind the camera
bringing you all the most amazing things
ascends all and we're gonna be heading
to chat but our attention was drawn by
the elephants so that's what we're doing
first this afternoon is watching them
and we're out on the boundary as well
we were lucky to catch them before they
crossed over to an area that we may not
venture so thank you elephant this is a
young bull that we're looking at to just
the two elephants yes so far the rest of
the herd could have crossed on nori tea
or perhaps it's just two members on the
side had a little boy a little bit
cheeky I don't blame him though probably
the heat I also get a bit grumpy when
I'm hot and sweaty but he should be
feeling much better now as he's
glistening in the sunlight from all that
love he met pretty cool
hi guys so I don't know if it's mom and
youngster but you seem to be a bit too
big to be a youngster but their car just
to the right of him looks like a memory
glands are starting to swell so perhaps
that big bulge and Assad is not from
devouring and today's grass and leaf
buffet but perhaps there is a young calf
on its way nice is this now Sansa when
are we gonna see your favorite animal
when are we gonna see the Lions today
senseless as we're going to see lions
today let's hope that he's right that
was quite a nice and a nice thing that
that elephant did I don't know if you
saw it it sort of grabbed a piece of
grass and then there we go it's at some
of the game wiped it on its body I don't
know perhaps the mat is like a salad
dressing the leaves what's the matter
then and eat it you know Sam I feel like
you're issuing us all a challenge today
by saying that this the mud is nature's
sunscreen it is a deed and if you do
find yourself in need of some sunscreen
and you can't find any well there we go
leather on the mat although I don't know
if I'd want to use the mud that that
elephant has just used normally it's it
doesn't smell particularly nice and I
don't know what kind of parasites and
things may be in there but we've got a
goal we've got to get to Chitra and I'm
hoping that that massive body of water
and water
that is at Chitra of course Chitra
chattri dan is going to attract some
more of these elephants but steve has
got the same idea today with the heat
he's going to be chasing after watering
holes let's see where he has arrived
thank you very much Taylor we have found
ourselves at chellah pan very small
watering hole on the twin dams Road
coming south from camp and we have found
ourselves a couple of comb ducks
otherwise known as Knob build ducks and
they are letting the very characteristic
big knob on the top of the beak that the
male will have in the breeding season so
what I can assume is that possibly
that's a female with some juveniles or
there is a male that is not breeding at
all but the one on the left looks a
little bit more darby brown than the one
on the right but what a nice reflection
that is they are standing in a little
bit of shade enjoying some wind coming
off the water and it just goes to show
how a small pan like this which was dry
not so long ago the nutrients washing in
from the from the surrounding you will
slowly start to see vegetation growing
in this as the plants growing with the
influx of nutrients and that is what
these ducks are feeding on they are also
known as filter feeders so they're able
to filter small vegetation particles out
of the water with their sort of filter
like beaks which is quite unique for for
ducks
the only other birds species that we
know of they can filter are flamingos so
really nice to see them it's my first
sighting of some novel ducks in the last
one three banded plover
Puma thinks oh very odd Puma you should
see what the mail looks like when he is
breeding he has got this very large disc
shape on his beak I would show you on my
phone but I think the screen is not
going to reflect it very well but there
they are they're quite DAB looking at
the moment I'll actually try and get a
picture for you but they are quite
interested in the Impala that just
walked off there were two male and Paula
enjoying the same shade as they were and
they are constantly looking in the
direction see if I can find you a nice
picture comb I don't know why they're
called comb ducks but not bill makes it
very easy to comb duck is the old name
let's see if we can get this fig let's
see if we can get the reflection on here
look at the size of that knob on the top
of the beak on the mail apparently that
is extremely attractive to the females
which I find quite bizarre but each to
their own you can see sort of the Flex
oh sorry about my head you can see the
flex on the neck which are quite
characteristic for this duck with that
sort of dirty whiteness to them what's
there calling an alarm call of something
on the floor here so yes they are quite
strange ducks but when they fly in
profile they've got such an amazing sort
of shape because that big comb or knob
on the top there
okay sir mr. Dyson is up and mobile and
he would like to say good afternoon good
afternoon hello everyone my name's Scott
I'm teamed up with Devon we're in the
rush we are looking for a leopard his
footprints were right behind us very
fresh and we've heard some monkeys alarm
calling so we are hoping that sooner
rather than later we are going to be
able to work out exactly where the slip
it is not too sure which mail it could
be maybe tumba maybe who can worry maybe
10 Ghana a lot going on with the male
leopards here on Duma at the moment and
I'm hoping that these monkeys that we've
heard alarm call a little bit earlier
continue to do so steaming and this was
the area where the Hoku more email was
finishing off a kill yesterday tailors
already put through her guess she thinks
it's gonna be a tumba a young male never
good enough well long enough chance to
check those tracks properly and like I
said there could have been hookah
worries but interestingly enough welcome
or emails got quite distinctive toes
some of his toes are longer than the
others especially as back right foots is
back right foots this toes considerably
longer than that one and that's abnormal
Rickson pointed that out to me the other
day
Rickson is one of our wizard trackers
where we spend time with on foot
hmm okay it's time to go off the road I
want to try and work out where these
vervet monkeys are they were chattering
away and they still around they'll
hopefully be up in a tree and looking in
the direction of where that threat was
we can just stop here for a moment and
enjoy these in Y all's Frances in Israel
you say it could be who can worry and
only time will tell
hopefully we will in fact be able to
find out who it is and then we will know
who is correct Taylor with tumba or
Francis in Israel with the hukam or
email now in the honor are quite big
antelope for leopard to take down
how cool is a shot the tangle of heads
and horns all different shapes and sizes
a great display actually small medium
and large or medium small large if you
were to go in order enlarge walk medium
small large if you were to go in order
wonderful as I say they're quite big
prey but not too big for wonderful as I
say quite big prey but not too big for a
male leopard too big for a female too
big for a female I've been really
surprised by animals and their long
hauls and how often it can vary
whiffle's and their long hauls and how
often it can vary with some in yellow
Bulls just like these ones we looking at
now that's cuz flaring is not these ones
we're looking at now that's cuz flaring
his nostrils quite quite effectively the
leopard walk probably about 10 or 15
meters / effectively the leopard walk
probably about 10 or 15 meters past him
and he didn't even let off one bark now
that is not very Austin and he didn't
even let off one bark now that is not
very good if his girlfriend's I'd have
seen him doing that they would have been
extremely extremely disappointed be good
if it's girlfriends that have seen him
doing that they would have been
extremely extremely disappointed what is
this guy chewing I'm wondering if he's
chewing and marilla fruits I think it
could be he's been going at it by
chewing I'm wondering if he's chewing
and marilla fruits I think it could be
he's been going at it for quite a while
that's if we can see in his beak there
hey buddy yours that's if we can see in
his beak there hey buddy you also
getting a bit flaring nostril there
showing off hmm I wish I could twitch my
ears lacking in Jana that would be a
nice party trick giving a bit flaring
nostril there showing off hmm I wish I
could twitch my ears lacking in Jana
that'll be a nice party trick okay guys
we gonna probably move on from these in
Jana keep snooping about try and find
out where the vervet